i really had to get myself together
because i do have kids and i do have
you know a family that i have to just be
positive and get it together for kim
kardashian is not looking to move on
romantically just yet
amid speculation that she's preparing to
divorce her husband
kanye west after six years of marriage
a source tells et that the pair is on
solid and amicable terms
though kim is ready for any decision she
needs to make especially when it comes
to their four children
seven-year-old north five-year-old saint
three-year-old chicago
and one-year-old song that's really all
i want to focus on
the source says that kim definitely has
all her ducks in a row with regards to
the kids
and financials in case she decides to
officially file for divorce
the source goes on to say that quote kim
still loves and supports kanye
and wants the best for him and their
entire family but is worried and
concerned that kanye is not mentally
stable enough
to be the dad their family needs i
believe no matter what's going on in
your life
you can't take that time to grieve for a
second no matter what it is
what you're grieving feel those feelings
and then
figure out how to be positive about it
because it's not going to change
in terms of how kim is coping with
everything according to the source
spending time with her family helps i
just think like we're definitely a close
family
like more than probably normal kim
recently shared this adorable birthday
post for her three-year-old niece stormi
who was seen enjoying some girl time
with cousin chicago
true and dream the source says quote
there have been lots of playdates and
family time
which is exactly what the entire family
thinks kim needs right now
come and get another day
as far as if the kids know what's going
on according to the source
they have an idea quote kim tries to
keep it light
and position the situation as a good
thing that their dad is taking some time
to reflect and get healthy
and that they will see him soon when
he's doing better i've seen him go
through
a lot and he's just the most genuine
person and you know he might say things
that
might get misinterpreted and people
don't see the context behind it but i
always know his heart
as for dating anyone new the source says
quote
neither kim nor kanye are interested in
dating anyone at this time
last month the source told et that kanye
not being around
isn't shocking to the kids because kanye
has always been busy traveling
the source went on to say that at the
end of the day kim and kanye will do
what's best for their kids
and are on great terms as parents
[Music]
you